you're watching the daily climate show
on sky news coming up on today's
programme
canada on the front line we explore how
warmer oceans around the philippines
might be creating weather havoc in the
pacific northwest
indonesia is set to make the most of its
geography and develop tidal power
and the magic of mushrooms how
underground fungi networks are crucial
to the fight against climate change
[Music]
hello and welcome to the uk's only daily
climate news show where we track the
changes happening to our world right now
and challenge those coming up with the
solutions
now residents of british columbia are
bracing themselves for more torrential
rainfall today while still clearing up
from the flooding caused by intense
rains which hit the region just two
weeks ago
environment canada has issued a series
of weather alerts with some areas
expecting up to 20 centimetres of rain
well the weather pattern responsible is
called an atmospheric river
now it's best described as a river in
the sky and transports columns of water
vapour evaporated from warm oceans
through the atmosphere now the river
carries huge quantities of water vapour
equivalent to the amount found at the
mouth of the mississippi river now
passing through hawaii the rivers are
often referred to as the pineapple
express now when the water vapor cools
the river makes landfall releasing water
as rain or snow which is what we've seen
recently across the pacific northwest
now off the shores of the philippines is
an area called the indo-pacific warm
pool now it has some of the warmest
ocean temperatures in the world and
according to researchers this pool has
been expanding and warming in the past
century due to climate change
now scientists believe that this
expansion of this area to the north
means more moisture is joining the
pineapple express and continuing across
the ocean resulting in atmospheric
rivers which are wider and longer with
more extreme results
well the region is no stranger to
record-breaking weather in june one
village in british columbia recorded
49.6 degrees celsius that's canada's
highest ever temperature
we're joined now by dr rachel white
who's assistant professor in earth ocean
and atmospheric sciences at the
university of british columbia so
welcome to you first of all what impact
do you think that climate change is
having on these levels of moisture in
the so-called pineapple express that we
were just talking about and what could
that mean for the pacific northwest in
the future
yeah good to be with you um great
questions and it is it's a really
important question to be thinking about
and as you said there's there's very
clear research that says that as we warm
up the oceans as we warm up the
atmosphere we are going to have more
moisture in the atmosphere and what that
means for events like this these these
atmospheric rivers is that when they're
holding more moisture when they're
holding more water vapor in the
atmosphere when they hit into the
mountains particularly around the
pacific northwest and that moisture is
condensed and falls out as rainfall we
are going to see heavier
rainfall extremes and heavier events and
so certainly the the fingerprint of
climate change is on the strength of
these atmospheric rivers that we're
seeing right now
and just a few months ago we were
talking about extreme heat waves in in
this part of canada is that just an
unhappy coincidence that
this area has been hit by extreme
weathers of different kinds
that's a really great question and so
climate change plays a strong role in
both of these events and so heat
extremes as we are warming up the
climate we are going to see uh stronger
and more frequent heat extremes and as
we just said as we warm up the climate
we're also going to see stronger heavy
rainfall events the fact that we've seen
sort of these two extremes over british
columbia i think is just bad luck
there's nothing sort of in
the
the background conditions you're sort of
talking about sea surface temperatures
there are there are a number of things
that are making it more likely that we
would see these atmospheric rivers this
year but there's nothing that sort of
says we should have had such an extreme
heat wave followed by such extreme
rainfall events so i think this is a
combination of bad luck for british
columbia and climate change making these
things worse
however is canada particularly
vulnerable to climate change
i think there certainly are um parts of
canada yes um and so here in the pacific
northwest we are very vulnerable to
these atmospheric rivers it's sort of a
combination of as you were sort of
describing with the map that we have all
of this moisture coming from the pacific
ocean we also see atmospheric rivers in
over the atlantic as well and so part of
what causes such the extreme rainfall
here is that we have some very high
mountains here and so that pushes the
air upwards which causes the water to
condense
we also there's a lot of very cold
regions in canada and so the melting of
glaciers the melting of snowmelt
contributes to flooding
we have sea level rise affecting the
coastal regions we have
particularly indigenous communities in
the northern parts of canada sort of
dependent on sea ice dependent on sort
of very coastal communities that are
very impacted by sea level rise
so right there are a lot of reasons why
we are vulnerable um and you know ev
every country is vulnerable in slightly
different ways that's the scary thing dr
rachel white thanks very much indeed
thank you
now let's take a look now at some of the
day's other climate news and the former
leader of the green party caroline lucas
has led a debate on the well-being
economy in parliament now she argued
that we must change our economic model
to focus on sustainability instead of
gdp in order to successfully tackle
climate change
it can't be overestimated enough that
shifting from growth to well-being is
critical from a social and equity
perspective too
as a report by leading economists for
the oecd fines patterns of economic
growth have generated significant harms
over recent decades including recent
rising inequality not just catastrophic
environmental degradation which itself
hits the most vulnerable the hardest
scientists have predicted that by 2080
more rain than snow will fall in the
arctic projections published in the
journal nature communications show a
steep increase in rain that will occur
decades earlier than originally thought
the study's authors say the shift is due
to rapid warming and sea ice loss in the
arctic
plastic packaging on supermarket shelves
has been cut by 10
over the past three years
that's according to the charity rap who
say the reduction is equivalent to
taking 150 000 cars off the road but the
charity warned that more items need to
be recyclable as currently less than a
fifth of plastic items can be recycled
and scientists are demanding that
weasels be given legal protection
because of falling numbers a study of 37
species found that weasels are
disappearing faster than any other small
mammals with numbers halving over the
past 50 years according to researchers
the scale of decline is enough to
justify it being classified as
vulnerable to extinction
now the ocean is a vast and almost
untapped resource of renewable energy
tidal power those countries with long
coastlines are especially well placed to
benefit and a uk company nova innovation
has won funding to study the feasibility
of a tidal energy project in indonesia
which currently depends hugely on fossil
fuels for its energy and is made up of
thousands of islands well tom wills is
nova's offshore manager and he joins me
now so tell us why indonesia why might
it be suitable for tidal power
it's just an amazing place probably one
of the most promising locations anywhere
in the world for tidal power
so you've got 17 000 islands about 6 000
of them inhabited it's just a vast
country if you put one end of indonesia
on the western end of spain
then the other end of indonesia is in
tehran so and you have the pacific and
the indian oceans sloshing in and out of
that huge archipelago every six hours so
it's a it's a clean and predictable
tidal energy resource that has yet to be
harnessed and at the moment indonesia i
think 80 percent of its energy its
electricity production comes from fossil
fuels so what contribution do you think
that tidal power could potentially play
yeah and i mean in indonesia their
electricity consumption set to double i
think within the next five or so years
it's just you know really
exponential growth there so
as far as tidal goes there's about 18
gigawatts so 18 nuclear power stations
worth of potential in indonesia
this is a feasibility study which we
hope is going to lead to the world's
sorry the world's first tyler ray was in
shetland where i am now and this would
be indonesia's first title array
and that would be an array of seven
megawatts but that's really just
scratching the surface of that huge
potential
and you mentioned what you're doing
there in the shetland islands but why is
it such an unusual project what you're
doing there why is tidal power not war
widespread
yeah it's been a kind of slow
development path but it's certainly
ramping up now i mean we've got four
turbines here at the moment another two
going in next year in order for 15 in
canada we're looking at projects in
wales and elsewhere
we're following a similar development
pathway to
what we've seen in solar and wind
but we just by the sheer nature of the
fact it's difficult to do things in the
sea it's a sea water is a corrosive
fluid and we have to work around weather
windows and
there's a lot of technical challenges to
do with operating in the sea which i
think have meant that tidal power has
not developed as fast as other
technologies but we have an opportunity
here for scotland and the uk to be an
international exporter of power
technology in a way that we missed out
in the development of solar and wind
power although we had an early lead in
the wind power industry this is really
an opportunity for scottish technology
to be exported around the globe
tom wills thanks very much indeed
thank you
now here's something a little bit
unexpected fungi play a crucial role in
our ecosystem and in tackling climate
change beneath our feet billions of tons
of carbon dioxide flow every year from
plants into an underground fungal
network and today the society for the
protection of underground networks or
spun say they've received their largest
ever donation to help map and preserve
these fungi so let's find out more about
how they work
underground there are these vast fungal
networks that are key in fighting
climate change
if i were to hold
a handful of soil it would already have
about a hundred kilometers of fungal
network in it
so what the fungal network is doing is
it's growing out and foraging in the
soil for phosphorus and nitrogen and
exchanging that for carbon from the host
root
when land is taken out of its natural
state and tilled or or the soil is
disrupted this physically breaks apart
these networks releasing huge amounts of
carbon along with it
we want to collect about 10 000 samples
in the next 18 months
[Music]
do stay with us coming up after the
break i'm going to be joined by the
environmental lawyer tessa khan and mike
berners-lee a leading carbon
footprinting expert and we're going to
be discussing how a well-being economy
could help in the fight against climate
change and ask if we could be doing a
better job at reducing our use of
plastic
i've teamed up with hp and the arbor day
foundation who last year planted a
million trees and this year plan to
plant a million more now a million trees
sounds like a huge amount but we need
more we're currently lagging way behind
europe 13 compared to 38
we need to up our game basically and we
need to start reforesting huge tracts of
land that
have been denuded of trees over the
years
we need to be very careful about the
type of trees that we plant ensuring
that it's native species learning from
our past mistakes but there are still
huge tracts of land um that can be
replanted reforested and that's why i've
teamed up with hp and arbor day to try
and encourage people to get behind us if
more businesses would start thinking
about the positive effect that trees can
have carbon capture for our mental
health uh there are so many benefits
that come from them
it seems to me to be a very obvious
thing that that we could target now of
course there are many tree planting
campaigns and i'm sure lots of your
viewers will have heard uh
about tree planting initiatives over the
years but just imagine if every single
person in the uk started
um planting
10 20 30 trees we we would be making a
huge difference i've seen a growing tide
of people who really do feel passionate
about making a difference we're hearing
about all the negatives but here is
something that we can actually do with
our own hands we can actually make a
positive difference we can actually get
into the ground and start planting those
trees i can't reiterate enough that you
need to be careful about what kind of
trees you plant we don't want any
species
anywhere you need to think about the
biodiversity and um and using native
species but i think we need to go back
to that i think if if we could have a
big campaign where everyone got behind
it
i think it could be something that would
empower people and put a smile on
people's faces
hp who have got behind this campaign
have committed to plant three trees for
every comment left on uh the video on my
instagram account now this is one part
of their
forest positive initiative this is this
is about trying to become carbon neutral
and trying to empower people and give
people the opportunity to actually make
a difference
i love my job because
i get to do something that is
contributing to a better future
[Music]
did you know if more of us walked rolled
bikes and scooted to school we would
make a big difference to the air
pollution around our school yeah like us
wednesday will start chilly and windy
with showers around some heavy and
squally there'll be a mix of sunny
spells and blustery showers through the
morning with hail and thunder possible
there'll also be some snow on northern
hills it'll be rather cold again with a
raw northerly wind bringing coastal
gales the afternoon will be similar but
southern scotland northern ireland and
northwest england should dry up later
looking at the uk's air pollution levels
will remain low measuring just two or
three on the daily air quality index
the air quality report sponsored by
phillips air purifiers
hello and welcome back to the daily
climate show on sky news and we're
getting straight to discussing the
climate issues of the day now with the
director of uplift tessa khan and
director at small world consulting mike
berners-lee so good evening to both of
you nice to see you both and first of
all calls in parliament today for a
complete change in the way our economy
works rather than focusing on gdp a
well-being economy could prioritize
people and the planet so what do our
guests make of this mike berners-lee
those who are pushing this idea of a
well-being economy say that the uk
economy at the moment is set up to
benefit the few at the expense of the
planet is that really fair
yeah i mean we talk about the response
to climate change often as if it's some
kind of hair shirt we're all going to
have to wear and it's it's so not right
if we get this right there's an
opportunity as we get on top of climate
change to all live better than we've
ever lived and not least by pursuing
things that are actually in the best
interests of people and planet and gdp
was actually never intended to be um the
metric that we guide our economy by um
but we've kind of slipped into using it
and it's such a bad proxy for anything
that's actually in our interest to
pursue so just making that simple shift
away from being locked into gdp
into just pursuing metrics like human
well-being environmental well-being is
it sounds so obvious but i mean that's
uh would be critical for us will be
critical for us uh so i can see you
nodding and yet there will be people
that say
what's wrong with gdp what's wrong with
a bit of growth isn't that what pulls
people out of poverty
now tessa i can't hear you apologies
yeah i was just going to say anna but i
think the problem with gdp is that as a
number on its own it tells you nothing
at all about how
gains or growth is distributed actually
and we know that um you know figures
that showed an increase in gdp after the
financial crisis didn't illustrate that
most of those gains went to the already
wealthy
and that those weren't distributed in a
way that increased equality in our
society but i mean to give you a more
concrete example of why looking at gdp
or production alone
doesn't tell you anything about how
close we are to tackling the climate
crisis i mean one thing that the uk
produces a lot of which would look great
on a gdp focused spreadsheet is oil and
gas
and yet we know according to the
international energy agency that we
can't have any new production of oil or
gas if we're going to stay within safe
climate limits so clearly gdp alone is
not going to tell us what we need to
know in terms of shifting away from
those really damaging practices and
industries in our society
and mike it's not necessarily a new idea
i know in the in his review earlier this
year professor separate
gupta said that his overarching aim is
the reconstruction of economy economics
to include nature as an ingredient but
don't ideas like that involve huge
societal changes that could take
generations and actually we need action
now
yeah that's right and the idea has been
around for decades at least and you know
as i said before gdp was never even
intended to be you know the ultimate
thing that the economists pursue
so and we do need uh really urgent
change right now but the good news is
that um you know it is possible it feels
like we've been locked into this weird
gdp simplistic metric but just just to
give an idea of how useless it is so if
you create a society for example where
nobody does anything for free to help
their friends or their neighbors
and they they charged for everything
then it's obviously a worse society to
live in but actually gdp goes up whereas
if you create a society where people
look after their neighbours just because
it's a nice thing to do gdp you know and
do things for free for each other gdp
actually goes down but the well-being of
people and probably planet goes up with
it so it's just it's completely
inadequate and you know it's
unsurprising to see that actually as to
date as gdp has grown actually so have
all our environmental
impacts so it's a big change because
we're so locked into many of our the
ways that we think about the economy but
i think more and more people i think
that that changes what we need to make
sure
something that people might want to
aspire towards give us very briefly if
you can a little vision of what it could
look like and how quickly we could make
changes
well i think there are a lot of great
proposals for alternative ways of
assessing the health of our economies
and societies and making sure that we
live within planetary boundaries but i
think it is worth emphasizing that while
we
encourage and embrace those really
systemic shifts um there are all sorts
of very obvious steps that governments
in particular could take right now to
ensure that we do keep living within
planetary limits and one of the things
that caroline lucas highlighted is that
governments are currently including the
uk government is currently subsidizing
fossil fuel production oil and gas
production to the tune of billions of
pounds um and that if they were to stop
doing that right away that would you
know vastly improve our chances of being
able to stay within those limits and of
course world leaders all signed up to
reducing inefficient subsidies didn't
they at cops so perhaps that will happen
let's move on though shall we because as
we were hearing earlier new research
shows plastic packaging on supermarket
shelves has been cut by 10
over the past three years but is it
enough and whose responsibility should
it be to reduce the use of plastics so
mike 10 cut in plastic packaging are you
impressed or are you disappointed
well it's worth having but in the scheme
of things we need to do a lot more
overall plastic production is is going
up uh still and if you if you now look
at all the discarded plastic in the
world that's all happened virtually all
happened over just the last 50 years
if it was cling film it would be enough
to wrap the planet up in this stuff
about one and a half times over and we
have no idea whatever how to ever get
this stuff out of our ecosystem again it
in time it breaks into smaller and
smaller pieces but it just turns up in
the most remote parts of the ecosystem
and as far as we know it'll be it'll be
pretty well there for all time so you
know it seems such a simple thing go to
the supermarket buy something in a
plastic packaging and you and somehow
you don't look after it properly and it
ends up being trashed and discarded into
the ecosystem and actually just think
about it it is there forever so this is
a huge thing that we need to make um you
know faster change on them than we are
at the moment it's good we've seen a
little bit of change so far tessa do we
need some plastic packaging in order to
keep food fresh to give consumers the
chance to
hang onto their food for a bit longer
well actually i think anna um that we
need to talk about really who's
responsible for the amount of plastic
packaging in our supermarkets and you
know i think it's really commendable
when individual customers who have the
time and the budget to choose products
that come with less packaging make those
choices but actually you know there are
certain industries that are really
driving the expansion of plastics and
the oil and gas industry is again one of
those industries that sees its future in
increasing the market for plastic
production as people stop needing to put
you know oil in their cars
petrochemicals are the big alternative
new market for their products and what
we really need to do is make sure that
we're regulating those companies
ensuring that they're not lobbying
against environmental regulation
including on plastic packaging for
example i think rather than continuing
to put the onus on individual consumers
to make the right choice you know often
difficult circumstances i just want to
get right to get to respond to that do
you think it is governments regulating
businesses that's the answer here micro
of individuals got a part to play
well people ask is it this group or is
it that group and actually it's all
groups so individuals can do something
about this by choosing which products
they buy and which shops they go to
uh but the shops themselves especially
the supermarkets for example you know
have a huge responsibility to
look at their supply chains and get the
plastic out of their packaging and
there's tons and tons that be done on
that and just by the way that's not
letting the governments off the hook
they can do an awful lot through
regulation as well between those three
sources of pressure we can get rapid
change so everyone basically okay mike
berners-lee jessica thanks very much
indeed
well that's everything from us for today
on tomorrow's show i'll be joined by
mikhail nachmany from climate policy
radar and senior lecturer in climate law
at edinburgh university navraj gali
do stay tuned here on sky news though
because coming up on sky news tonight
we'll examine the government's plans to
scale up the booster rollout that's
coming up next
[Music]